la journée mondiale de la santé c'est la
journée qui permet d'abord et avant tout
de rendre hommage au personnel soignant
à tous ceux qui soignent chacune et
chacun d'entre nous qui font face cette
pandémie et qui au quotidien font se
fasse à l'ensemble des maladies et des
difficultés auxquelles nous sommes
parfois les uns et les autres confrontés
c'est l'occasion de rendre hommage à
leur dévouement l'occasion aussi de dire
l'action du gouvernement au travers du
ségur de la santé où comme au travers du
plan massif d'investissements qui a été
décidé par le premier ministre est de
faire en sorte que nous projetions dans
l'intérêt et puis cette journée c'est
aussi l'occasion de rendre hommage à la
science et à la recherche
en un peu plus d'un an on a à la fois
puis identifiées virus le séquencé et on
a pu trouver les voies et moyens
d'inventer
au fond un vaccin ce qui est un record
absolu dans l'histoire de l'humanité
désormais nous sommes en phase de
vaccination et de production de vaccins
au service de chacune et chacun d'entre
nous et ça permet aussi de se dire
l'importance de la science et de la
recherche dans l' aventure humaine dans
le progrès humain
nous aurons sans aucun doute d'autres
pandémies
défis en termes scientifiques et c'est
par la science par la recherche par le
progrès que nous arriverons à les
surmonter